anemia distribución de vacunas
inmigración los reclamos de los
presidentes latinoamericanos el
presidente de perú pedro castillo se
estrenó en la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas y tras criticar la
gestión mundial de las vacunas propuso
un acuerdo internacional quiero plantear
en nombre del perú la firma de un
acuerdo mundial entre los jefes de
estado y los propietarios de las
patentes para garantizar el acceso
universal a las vacunas para todos los
habitantes del planeta sin
discriminación ni privilegios por su
parte el presidente brasileño jair
bolsonaro quien hasta el momento no se
ha vacunado defendió su manejo de la
crisis del cobro y 19 que le ha causado
una fuerte aprobación internacional tras
la muerte por el virus de 590 mil
personas en su país
apoyamos la vacunación sin embargo
nuestro gobierno se ha opuesto al
pasaporte sanitario oa cualquier
obligación relacionada con la vacuna
relacionada a battión el presidente de
colombia iván duque que intervino por
última vez ante la asamblea general de
la onu se refirió a la vacunación y a
los desafíos del mundo para luchar
contra la pandemia convoco a la
comunidad internacional a fortalecer el
multilateralismo en materia de salud y
avanzar en la equidad para la
distribución de las vacunas el tema de
la migración venezolana también fue el
foco de los discursos duke dijo que
colombia ha acogido a millones de
venezolanos y que espera que los países
comprometidos ayuden financieramente el
presidente de ecuador guillermo lasso
quien asistió por primera vez a la onu
tras su posesión este año entregó el
balance de la recepción de migrantes a
su país donde dice han recibido 433 mil
ciudadanos venezolanos